in the case of the Senate at recess it's
scheduled next week Lindsey Graham was
among the first Republicans to say to
Chuck Schumer who is of course the
Senate Majority Leader uh maybe we
should should stop that recess make sure
we're here just in case it's necessary I
want to raise that issue with Senator
John Kennedy the Louisiana Republican
kind enough to join US senator what do
you think of that idea don't take the
recess next week be around just in case
well I I can't speak for my colleagues
Neil all I can tell you is that
when a deal is reached and I think one
will be
I'll be here to vote on it
um rain or shine night or day
on this issue as most issues I'm a I
guess I'm an optimist who worries I'm
encouraged that President Biden and
speaker McCarthy are are talking they
don't have to work together to solve
this problem they just have to work in
the same zip code and I think they're
doing that and whatever the president
and the speaker can come up with I
predict will pass both the house and the
Senate with Republican and Democratic
support now that that doesn't mean it'll
be unanimous I don't know whether I'll
vote for it because I don't know what it
is yet but but I think they'll come up
with something you know what I've got
you Senator they're revealing uh
you know the portrait of Paul Ryan or
the former speaker uh The Well of the
house right now and I'm just wondering
well Ryan of course has been a Critic uh
of the the what he calls the severe
rightward mag alerts of the of your
party uh and the the out
position role of Donald Trump in that
party uh and then there are others I
guess they're called rhinos Republicans
the name only who are part of the same
party and there's always this Hatfield
and Mccoy's arguing back and forth what
do you think of that does it worry you
Paul Ryan is among those who said the
Republicans will lose with Donald Trump
the direction is it has to be a little
bit more mainstream to invite
Independents in any thoughts on any of
that senator
well I think both parties uh have
factions
there's also a moon wing of the
democratic party
um which is the Loon wing of the
Republican Party
well we have our factions as well and
and I have some colleagues that that
that may be moonlike but I I don't think
that I don't think we have a faction
that is this as Extreme as the
nauseously woke wing of the democratic
party but we can save that discussion
for another day I think whatever uh the
president and the speaker come up with
will pass now you'll probably have a lot
of Democrats and a lot of Republicans
who won't like it yeah but you'll have
enough Republicans and enough Democrats
who will say we're going to pass it so
so we don't default on America's debt
and I think it'll pass that's just my
opinion you know Senator you mentioned
the Loon Wings in each party as you know
Democrats have been coming out and
pouncing on your remarks regarding
Mexico uh and you know in which you said
without us the Mexicans would be eating
cat food out of a can and living in a
tent behind find an Outback you also
suggested the U.S invade Mexico to
subdue the drug cartels anyway people
like Robert Kennedy Jr and others are
coming out and saying that that that's
that's crazy that's going one step too
far what do you say right
well I love the people of Mexico I hate
the cartels
um and president Lopez obrador
who who is the president of Mexico he
ran on a slogan with respect to the
cartels of hugs not bullets well that's
not working out too well for him uh but
I think what they were referring what
you said about the Mexicans in general
about is that they'd be eating cat food
out of a can an attempt by now what do
you have colorful Language Center but
you think that got too cold
what I said was that we should use what
I proposed to the head of DEA was that
she and the president called the
president of Mexico and asked if the
American Military and the American law
enforcement can come into Mexico under
the supervision of the American Military
of the Mexican military and the Mexican
law enforcement and let us work together
to eradicate the the uh the cartels
because we know who they are and we know
where they are
and I suggested to the DEA secretary
that we use America's economic leverage
to try to convince the president of
Mexico perfect sense we explained that
to me I guess what I'm asking you sir
and they're not meaning to badge you on
this point but Robert F Kennedy Jr is
regrets the fact that some people might
think you're related to him he went that
far I'm just wondering do you think the
way you explained it to me just now
would have been probably the better way
to explain it well I think if you look
at first of all I don't know Mr Kennedy
he's entitled to his opinion number two
I think if you go look
at my entire remarks you'll understand
the context in in which I said it but at
Mexicans who feel that you know you you
went further than that to sort of malign
all of them you you would say
I would say that's not true I love the
people in Mexico but I hate their
cartels
and president Lopez oberdorp needs to
stand up to the cartels because they're
poisoning our children and I don't
understand why he would not invite and
why frankly President Biden would not
ask for it he would not invite our
military and our law enforcement
Personnel invite to come into Mexico and
work under and with his military and his
law enforcement officials and let us try
to wipe out the cartels we know who they
are we know where they are we know what
they're doing
and then both countries would be better
off because the cartels are crushing
small business in Mexico through
extortion and they're killing Americans
through Fenton
and I think most fair-minded people know
that what I just said is true I think
president Lopez Oberlin knows that what
I just said is true but he is looking
for a way to distract and from from uh
from what I think is my logic to say
well Kennedy is a racist
you know everybody's a racist now it
seems if we're all racist and nobody's a
racist
but you you don't take back any of those
other words just to be clear that thing
that's interesting if you'll go no
nothing if
if to the tape to the entire remarks I
have
well then I think you'll understand at
least from my point of view what what I
was saying and why I was saying it I
don't uh but but that's just me but
Senator thank you well you're you're
entitled to your opinion absolutely as a
user but thank you very very much it's
very good seeing you again uh Senator
John Kennedy the Louisiana Republican
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else